Morganthaul!
let's finish this
Welcome back everyone this is going to be my
marvel falcon and winter soldier episode 6 finale
video there were a whole bunch of easter eggs
obviously some post-credits scenes telling you
what's happening next with all these characters
so we'll break it all down if you're brand new to
the channel i'm doing videos for all the marvel
disney plus series this year loki episodes are
going to be next so be sure to subscribe to
get those episodes and careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the falcon and winter
soldier episodes yet we'll just start at the
beginning of the episode and number these as we
go along talking about easter eggs and wtf moments
the title of the episode was one world one people
which was the motto of the flag smashers and they
sort of called back to that with falcon's big
speech at the end but the actual episode starts
with Karli's voiceover talking to the other
flag smashers calling them to action saying
the grc won't stop unless they make them then they
jump right back to the moment where they left off
at the end of episode 5 right after the flag
smashers had taken the main grc council hostage
and taken over the building in new york city
it feels like a little bit of time has gone by
though like a small time jump enough time that
all the law enforcement agencies had posted
up around the building waiting to make a move
winter soldier has arrived in his full battle
gear falcon tells him on the comms that he's got
some backup coming and sharon carter surprises him
using that face swap digital technology from the
winter soldier movie you remember that's the same
tech the black widow used to disguise herself as
the older hydra woman she jokes about not getting
that pardon obviously big setup for the end of
the episode where she's revealed as the power
broker yes we'll talk about that because there was
some weird stuff happening with her storyline when
she's joking about not getting the pardon bucky
also references his therapist from earlier in the
series because him going to see the therapist was
part of the deal that the government gave him when
they partnered him like you have to go see this
therapist as part of your pardon falcon flies
overhead you get just a brief glimpse of that
captain america upgraded wing suit the vibranium
wing suit that the wakandans gave him when Karli
says he's here and looks up in the sky obviously
she's referencing falcon showing up she activates
the flagsmasher's plan they throw gas bombs into
the room causing the grc council members to run
down the stairs they're basically hurting them
like cattle so they can use them as hostages
but conveniently the first place that they run
to is that giant room with all the windows
facing the street so that falcon can easily
crash in with the shield revealing his new captain
america suit it looks pretty much what i expected
it to look like just a version of his suit that he
got when he became captain america in the comics
except in the comics it wasn't vibranium it was
just a regular upgraded suit like his falcon suit
they use a bunch of calculated action scenes
different types of action scenes during the
episode different fight scenes to show you all
the different abilities that his suit has too
but there's several lines of dialogue that they
give to other characters around falcon reacting
to him in the captain america suit to set him
up to talk about himself as captain america like
one of the grc members instantly asked him wait a
minute who are you so that he can say i'm captain
america but it's basically him acknowledging
that he is becoming captain america like i
fully decided to take the mantle and that's
why i'm wearing this suit i think there were at
least two or three other black falcon jokes in the
episode with different characters referring to him
as black falcon which is a call back to the joke
from earlier when he went to see isaiah bradley
the first time with that little kid wait a minute
you're black falcon right no i'm just falcon
then batrock surprises him wearing a flag smasher
mask he made it very clear earlier in episode
5 that he doesn't give two craps about their
movement he was just using this as an opportunity
to kill falcon and because sharon carter was
supposedly going to pay him a ton of money so
while falcon is busy fighting him you have sharon
carter and winter soldier trying to deal with the
other flag smashers and obviously because of the
big reveal sharon carter being the power broker
this whole time she's sort of manipulating events
according to her plan manipulating events so that
she will get that pardon winter soldier also gets
on the call with Karli joking about fighting for
the wrong side obviously that's a reference
to him being hydra for all those years when
he says he failed twice fighting for something
bigger than himself he's referencing world war
ii where he kind of died in the train almost died
then was taken by hydra and then the second time
was avengers infinity war when the avengers failed
to stop thanos from snapping the infinity gauntlet
dusting half the universe i think we can call
fighting for the entire universe fighting for
something bigger than yourself like he's making
a subtle reference to her being this misguided
teenager like listen kid you're young you
think everything you're doing is the most
important thing in the world i fought to save
the universe don't talk to me about grand causes
but when they end the call she kind of implies
that she was purposefully trying to goad him
on stalling him for time just to take him out of
the equation so that he wouldn't be able to stop
the flag smashers from taking the hostages which
she succeeded in fantastically sharon carter even
shames him a little like you had one job one job
to do one other clue about sharon carter being
way darker now too is when she takes out that one
flag smasher super soldier with the mercury vapor
explosive device it literally melts his face off
that's how hardcore she is now doesn't even bat
an eyelash they have the big falcon versus batroc
fight scene or we could say captain america versus
batrog because he is acting as captain america
during the episode but just for the purposes of
this video while i'm talking about these parts of
the episode i'm going to continue to reference him
as falcons so that i don't get too twisted around
in my head their fight scene is pretty good though
they try to show that it's fairly even odds with a
slight advantage to falcon because of all his new
captain america wakanda tech in the shield like
batrack is clearly meant to be the better fighter
but falcon's able to use all of his gear and the
shield to knock him back long enough to get out
and after the flag smasher convoy with the grc
hostages the big twist though with his escape is
that he throws the shield to break the glass and
then flies out but because he's super high up the
shield just flies off into the night and he has to
take off after it to catch it in the air because
he has the wingsuit it's also a funny reference
to him just not having 100 percent mastered the
ability to bounce the shield off of anything and
get it to come back to him like he's still kind
of learning with the shield but you do notice how
they very specifically split up the flag smashers
between the land and the air that's so that
they could have this captain america wing suit
action scene just like the helicopter fight scene
in episode one to show you all the extra abilities
that his new wingsuit has he unveils the brand
new version of redwing thank you very much black
panther for the assist they show off more of its
ai functions it's able to scan the identities of
the grc member hostages to see if any of them are
capable of flying the helicopter so that he can
take out the flax smasher pilots without dooming
them all to crash in the river which he then does
using red wing he like he uses it to yoink him
right out the door mid-air which is a straight-up
spider-man move he does save him from falling to
his death and shields him with the new vibranium
wings and you do notice the way the camera
focuses on him it's very careful very measured
actions that he's taking so that everybody gets
a really good look at him now he's not doing it
that way he's just trying to save lives but the
way they filmed the episode they want to show you
everybody watching him and recording him on
their phones like they focus on all this crowd
cheering for him while he's doing this making
all these saves it's meant to be the opposite
of what happened to john walker when he killed
the flag smasher in episode 4. the title of that
episode was the whole world is watching watching
him besmirch the good name of captain america in
the shield this time the whole world was watching
falcon inspire all these people and give them the
big moral talking to at the end of the episode as
captain america but you do notice this continuing
theme throughout the episode as Karli starts
to slowly hulk out more and more like she goes
full john walker by the end of the episode some of
the other super soldiers even show signs of revolt
when she starts to go super hardcore talking about
dying for the cause like we're all definitely
going to die but as they take over the convoy they
give winter soldier that really cool motorcycle
action scene where he crashes over the barrier
to give him a flying punch with his vibranium arm
it's a great twist on steve rogers captain america
throwing his motorcycle at the hydro soldiers in
avengers age of ultron this time it's bucky using
the motorcycle to throw himself at people i was
kind of hoping they'd show off some more secret
abilities from his vibranium arm they did give
him some cool action scenes using the arm but not
quite as crazy as i was hoping for Karli starts a
fire around the hostages to distract bucky again
just to give him someone to save taking advantage
of his newfound good nature but this is obviously
all meant to be set up for john walker to enter
the fight so obviously he comes in shouting i
love the way they frame the shot they give him
this hero entrance but it's a very dark twist on
a hero entrance but they start by framing the shot
on his home depot looking shield full display
then they slowly pan up to his face of course
Karli says the worst possible thing she could say
implying that lamar doesn't matter i only want to
kill people who matter so you know exactly what
john walker is going to say before he says it
and a lot of people were just waiting to see what
would happen when he tried to use this homemade
shield of course it doesn't bounce the way the
vibranium captain america shield bounces so she
kicks it like a soccer ball and it just falls
to the ground notice you can see all the weld
points and the rivets in the back here but while
bucky is busy still trying to save the hostages
you have all the flag smashers tag teaming john
walker and they have him dead to rights like they
rip out the parking meter and they're gonna beat
him with it but bucky winds up saving his life
one of the first turns in the episode of john
walker slowly starting to chill out and doing
things in a more reasonable way even though there
were a lot of fight scenes it was a surprisingly
bloodless finale now there were a couple deaths
like i said sharon carter was shooting people
all over the place melting people's faces off
so i feel like her body count was actually one
of the highest of any of the characters in the
episode they have that really cool scene with
bucky using his vibranium arm to absorb the shock
of his landing when they whack him off the edge
of the cliff then he uses it to absorb the impact
of that girder when the super soldier attacks them
with it adding the force of their fall to the
blow that's the magic of vibranium right there
it absorbs kinetic energy it can also be used
to absorb regular energy damage too that's what
black panther's vibranium nanite suit is built to
do absorb kinetic and energy damage they show off
more of falcon's new captain america wingsuit
abilities as he gets knocked underwater into
the river notice how he's able to use his jetpack
propulsion and his wings form around him to form a
more hydrodynamic shape like a cone shape to make
it easier for the jet pack to push him up out of
the water and back into the air it kind of turns
him into a torpedo like a falcon torpedo then he
uses the shield to perform a bigger version of the
same stunt scene the same helicopter fly-through
move that he used in episode one basically
snatching the other flag smasher pilot right
out of his seat and through the other side then
back with the hostages we're kind of reaching the
turning point with john walker's character so he's
still trying to kill Karli at this point while
the fire is still burning near the other group of
hostages who are trapped screaming for their lives
the important thing here though is that unlike
winter soldier who stopped fighting the flag
smashers to save the one car load of people
before he got knocked away at least at this
point john walker isn't paying attention to the
hostages he's just still laser focused on Karli
he's kind of like a super soldier bull in a china
shop with that shield just taking those massive
swipes at her then she sets up that big safe scene
with the car trying to crash it off of the cliff
getting stuck on the girders this whole scene
becomes a big plot moment for some of the twists
later in the episode for the main characters
Karli's whole thing is that she wants to create
a scenario for the press for maximum attention
maximum emotional political impact with them just
hanging there by a thread getting ready to die but
this time john walker finally comes to his senses
so to speak and helps them or at least tries to
save them before the other flag smashers stop him
the whole public is gathered around watching
this with their phones just like they were
watching him during episode 4 watching him kind of
redeem himself a little bit so it's why later in
the episode julia louis dreyfus's character val
madame hydra whatever you want to call her is
more easily able to get him appointed as us agent
from the comics with his comic book accurate black
uniform all that stuff felt like a big thunderbolt
setup especially because it came hand in hand with
the zemo scene on the raft and that is thunderbolt
ross's personal prison but predictably it winds
up being a big setup for falcon to be the one to
save the day as captain america and for everyone
to see him all the public the press to watch him
save the day as captain america with his wingsuit
that's why the first thing to enter the frame when
everybody is reacting to this is the shield itself
like the shield enters frame then you see his
face in the rest of the wingsuit pushing the car
back up you also notice too that there
are a couple extra drones that break off
smaller pieces of red wing to help boost the car
back up i'm sure there's all kinds of other little
gadgets that he has built into the red wing there
then winter soldier saves john walker's life again
when Karli tries to spear him running through
with the rebar and falcon disables a couple
of the super soldiers with the shield they also
use batroc and all of his gas bombs to show you
how falcon's new visor can see through the gas
pretty much the whole first half of the episode
was just a tutorial in how falcon's new suit works
surprisingly john walker now officially teams up
with falcon and winter soldier to chase them down
through the tunnels this is obviously just more of
walker trying to do the right thing like he kind
of shaking himself out of full-blown serial killer
mode and wasn't trying to kill the flag smashers
anymore like okay we'll try to do things your way
now but as they shift to the underground tunnels
the episode kind of goes into thriller mode they
sort of switch gears just a little bit they have
their big sharon carter's standoff with Karli
which they used to reveal her as the power broker
that she's been the power broker this whole time
and she has this big conversation sort of
explaining their history together as well so
the whole idea here is that sharon carter became
the power broker built this little criminal empire
on madrapore after the snap in the blip as a way
to change the world that betrayed her so to speak
because remember she kind of felt like she was
cast aside like i didn't get the pardon that the
other avengers got because i wasn't an important
person then when the other flag smasher characters
originally came to madrapur after her she used
them as her muscle sort of taking Karli in
specifically because she reminded her of a younger
version of herself very naive and idealistic
but then eventually as she says Karli the others
rebelled stole the super soldier serum which she
was planning on selling to the highest bidder
and used it on themselves to start their plot
to stop the grc in turnabout is fair play double
crossing the double crosser she reveals that she
really hired betruck to spy on Karli at the summit
the whole time so that she would be able to stop
the flag smashers and save the hostages earning
herself the pardon manipulating all these events
the whole time to get that pardon later in
the episode we find out that so that she can
infiltrate the government in the military giving
her more access to special weapons prototypes
all manner of tech that she can then sell to
the highest bidder so they've kind of turned the
sharon carter character into more of a vowel like
madame hydra type of character not really a good
character anymore but not necessarily a totally
evil character as well i do have some complaints
about the way they plotted out the sharon carter
storyline mostly that it feels like we didn't get
enough with her character they kind of gave us
the cliff's nose version and it was the simplest
version of that plot like i think by halfway
through the episode even after episode three
i think most people believe that she was the power
broker which i don't think is a terrible direction
to go for her character but i feel like they
could have done a much better job of explaining
why she was doing all these things the explainer
that they gave us was kind of the you know make
a seinfeld reference because we have julia louis
dreyfus was kind of the yada yada yada explainer
for sharon carter like you kind of feel like steve
rogers would have probably checked in on her after
avengers end game just to make sure she was okay
but the way she tells it in the episode nobody
none of the avengers characters ever bothered
to check in on her which i don't know that i
buy totally but then batroc tries to blackmail her
demanding more money she kills him to prevent her
secret from getting out and because Karli is able
to shoot her while it's happening sharon carter is
able to make it look like she's the victim in all
this manipulating things when falcon comes running
up they show you a couple more of his new wingsuit
abilities during their fight scene although it's
more of a non-fight scene because he's trying to
de-escalate the situation while she keeps hooking
out screaming in his face screaming at him to
fight her he's just like iron man and that he
uses the technology to give him the same level of
abilities that a lot of the other traditionally
super-powered avengers have they have that funny
moment with john walker and winter soldier just to
show you that john walker has chilled out a little
he has that funny abraham lincoln quote mercy
bears richer fruit than strict justice which is
also a metaphor for him being less stabby now like
i am showing you mercy now instead of killing you
like i would have a couple episodes ago and the
richer fruit that this situation will bear for me
is my new position as us agent as opposed to being
thrown in the raft prison with zemo they also have
that funny buddy cop moment with winter soldier
right after to show you that there's no more hard
feelings between them which he also has later
with falcon so i think the whole idea with that is
that potentially when john walker comes back as us
agent in a new disney plus series or somewhere
else it'll be much easier to explain how he's more
of an anti-hero and less villain-like as he was
during say like episode four when he was killing
the flag smashers but then all those reporters
swarm falcon as he flies back in with her body
with a couple references and jokes to what his
new name is going to be is it still falcon is it
captain falcon like i said a lot of the black
falcon jokes during the episode but the whole
thing here is that he already introduced himself
at the beginning of the episode as captain america
answering all those questions if you're still
wondering like he is captain america now then
he meets with the senators including the senator
that he originally gave the shield back to in
episode one and sort of talks them down from going
forward with their plan to relocate the refugees
and gets them to find a better solution his whole
speech about them finding common ground with the
refugees is meant to be a slightly more reasonable
approach to the idea of the flag smashers one
world one people their whole motto and the title
of the episode like the less stabby approach
to their idea he makes a couple references to
avengers end game avengers infinity war and thanos
snapping the infinity gauntlet talking about the
grc's actions comparing them to erasing half the
planet then like i said they basically spend the
entire third act climax in a really long speech
that he gives to them like the writers want you to
think that this is the most important part of the
episode that's why they spend so much time in this
scene but they intercut it with a couple other
major characters reactions they show you isaiah
bradley's reaction like he's really surprised
and happy to see falcon as the new captain america
like oh wow this is actually pretty good when he
says he doesn't have any super soldier serum no
blonde hair or blue eyes he's referencing steve
rogers captain america because one even though
chris evans has brown hair for the most part in
the last couple marvel movies in his first couple
of marvel movies he was meant to have blonder hair
and blue eyes because comic book steve rogers has
blonde hair and blue eyes they cut to torres who's
watching the broadcast on his laptop in the air
force base that falcon always works out of and you
notice he's got all of his tools on the bench
there for fixing falcon's old wingsuit i feel
like that's another reference to him potentially
becoming the next falcon like he did in the comics
when falcon became the new captain america you
also probably spotted the w-h-i-h easter egg
they showed up on Wandavision too in the sword
headquarters on the broadcast they're sort of
like marvel's version of cnn in the mcu then
they set up the post-credits scene when falcon
says that he's going to help sharon carter get her
pardon like he said he would back in episode three
and this sort of let you know that the government
is acknowledging him as captain america when the
fbi agent comes up and asks falcon captain america
to grab that last flag smasher out of the river
but i don't know about you guys but this last
scene where they kill off the flag smashers i
actually laughed just a little bit like the
butler did it so as they're driving away
like the last four that are still alive zemo's
family butler from earlier in the series kills
them with a car bomb presumably on zemo's orders
according to his plan then just to confirm they go
to zemo's reaction listening to the news the next
day on the raft prison he smiles realizing that
his contingency plan was successful his whole goal
was to eliminate all the super soldiers so mission
accomplished and i don't speak german but maybe
somebody who does can translate the titles of
those books that are sitting there i think these
books might be the same ones that he had in his
prison back during episode two but the whole idea
is that he's just chilling here on the raft until
someone comes to recruit him for the thunderbolts
that's why right on cue very thunderbolt style
scene with us agent and julie louis-dreyfus
character here at the end val gets the alert the
same alert about the bombing of the flag smashers
the next day sort of joking that zemo got the last
laugh she also calls zemo their friend that's
why i feel like her character will be associated
with thunderbolts in the future wherever they
decide to surface that team it's probably going
to be a while before we see them i do love the way
she goes out on those dark jokes like things went
exactly the way that she wanted maybe she was
behind everything but maybe not but maybe just
having some fun with the idea that she is way more
powerful than she's let on the way the showrunners
and the producers talked about her recently in
interviews say that they set julie louis dreyfus
character up to be a dark version of nick fury
which was why i talk about thunderbolts when i
talk about her character like they wouldn't talk
about her as a darker version of nick fury without
her being responsible for setting some stuff up in
the future but they do have that funny scene with
john walker unveiling himself as the new comic
book looking us agent character in his comic book
accurate costume she even literally calls him
us agent and he literally says it's the exact
same costume except black they don't show you
his shield but his us agent shield is basically
the old captain america shield but just u.s in
the center of it but she basically sets up his
future potential thunderbolt spinoff series saying
that we're not going to need captain america for
the weird stuff that's coming we're going to need
a u.s agent implying that he's going to be doing
some really shady black ops stuff for her then
they had the ending scene with winter soldier
telling yuri the truth about killing his son when
he was hydra winter soldier and you see he left a
little gift for his therapist with all the names
being crossed out of the book including zemos
because zemo told him that he took the liberty
of crossing his own name out the reason why he
says he's finished the book and he's leaving it
to her like actually leaving her the real book is
because it's his way of saying that he's leaving
his past behind him like he's not going to cling
to that anymore then they have the big isaiah
bradley ending scene with falcon you also have
to remember too that his grandson here elijah
bradley is a version of patriot from the comics
a young avengers character so he could always come
back when they eventually do a young avengers team
up because it kind of seems like they're slowly
setting that up in the background of these disney
plus series but isaiah bradley sort of jokes
around with falcon a little bit referencing him
as this big special figure now like he accepts him
as captain america like okay i'm happy with what
you've done i'm proud of what you've done then
falcon reveals that they've added him and his
former squad bates from the weapons plus program
to the captain america exhibit then they go back
to falcon's home ending the episode with a party
to celebrate him becoming captain america with
all of his friends the other people from town
that they know the friends of the family in the
end titles read captain america and the winter
soldier so i think you know early prediction
if the show does wind up getting a season two
that that's what they'll call the show it won't
be falcon in winter soldier season 2 it'll just
be called captain america in the winter soldier
this is the closest thing we get to the mid-credit
scene the actual post-credits scene is sharon
carter getting the pardon from the senator he also
calls her agent carter like peggy carter and then
talks about the carter name in the history that
it has because she is peggy carter's grand niece
and offers her her old job back at the cia as
she walks away she calls her people as the power
broker back on madrapore saying that they got all
kinds of access to the weapons tech prototypes to
sell to potential buyers around the world but
super soldiers are off the menu steve rogers is
somewhere in outer space on that moon base they
made so many references to that moon base during
the series frowning down on her how could you
do this but i will do a couple more videos about
the other big plot teasers and thunderbolts dark
avengers talk that's been going around about them
setting that up in the background as well with
thunderbolt ross and red hulk stuff is there any
other big easter eggs that you spotted during the
episode that i didn't talk about during the video
just write them below in the comments or any big
questions that you have like i said the next big
marvel disney plus series is going to be loki
i'll be doing videos for all those episodes and
there'll be a couple more trailers in the next
month or so so leave all your video requests in
the comments below everyone click here to learn
all about russell crowe becoming zeus real god
in the marvel universe during thor 4 love and
thunder and click here for that brand new shang
chi trailer video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!